avec le micro allumé c'est quand même un
peu mieux mes chers collègues mesdames
messieurs nous reprenons cet après-midi
nos travaux sur la parentalité dans les
outre-mer mais en commun par les deux
délégations sénatoriales délégation
droit des femmes présidentées par ma
collègue en aiguillon et la délégation
d'outre-mer que j'ai l'honneur présidé
la présidente billon qui est à mes côtés
et à qui je donnerais la parole dans
quelques instants va devoir s'absenter
si les participants pouvaient par contre
couper leur micro
ça éviterait simplement un retour en
fait un écho je vous remercie beaucoup
donc je disais que la présidente billon
devra tout à l'heure s'absenter pour
participer à la séance publique et son
excuse par avance je vous rappelle que
nous sommes tout de quoi rapporteurs de
cette étude ainsi que deux de nos
collègues que je salue salut
heureusement Victorin victoire jasmin et
Elsa Salques depuis février vous avez
mené une série d'auditions nous avons
mené mais vous aussi également notamment
un déplacement tout récent dans les
vidéos les comptes rendus sont
disponibles sur le site du Sénat
pour toutes les études concernant les
outre-mer on nous organisons des tables
rangs géographiques afin d'appréhender
les spécificités de chaque territoire
au-delà du panorama d'ensemble que nous
avons commencé à dresser après Mayotte
et territoires du Pacifique nous allons
aborder aujourd'hui successivement la
situation en Guyane et à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon territoire que
je connais assez bien pour appréhender
les réalités ultra-marine au plus près
la présidente en aiguillon est de nos
corps-à-porteurs sont déplacés
en avril en Guadeloupe à Saint-Martin et
Saint-Barthélémy où elles ont eu un
programme très dense et ont été rejoints
par nos collègues sur place et certains
que ces visites de terrain sont de
nature à enrichir le rapport que nous
rendrons en juillet sur ces récents
échanges je sais de la parole à ni
billon pour partager son témoignage et
ses observations
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
chers Stéphane bonjour à tous et à
toutes je me réjouis effectivement
d'avoir pu me rendre il y a quelques
jours avec nos collègues co-rapporteurs
elles achent et victoire jasmin en
Guadeloupe Saint-Martin et
Saint-Barthélemy comme vient de le
préciser le président Stephen Artano
afin d'échanger avec des acteurs
institutionnels associatifs de terrain
nous avons eu la chance et le privilège
aussi finalement d'être accompagné par
notre collègue Micheline Jacques qui
tout comme victoire jasmin connaît
particulièrement ces territoires où
elles habitent nos entretiens nous ont
permis de mieux appréhender les
problématiques spécifiques à ces
territoires sur notre thématique de la
parentalité de nombreuses personnes
souvent précaires une fréquence absence
des pères dès la naissance des enfants
les deux tiers de ses enfants n'étant
pas reconnu par leur père un fort taux
d'IVG et de grossesse précoce un manque
de structure d'accueil des jeunes
enfants des problèmes de décrochage et
d'absentéisme scolaire ainsi que des
violences intrafamilales qui demeurent
élevés nous avons aussi rêvé un sujet
autour de la maîtrise de la langue
française pour les parents notamment
d'origine étrangère ne parlant que
créole ou bien qu'en anglais ce qui est
fréquent à Saint-Martin les échanges
avec l'école et les institutions sont
souvent complexes nos rencontres nous
ont également permis de constater
l'engagement de nombreux acteurs sur les
questions de parentalité en tout premier
lieu la CAF de Guadeloupe et
Saint-Martin dont l'action volontariste
a été saluée par tous nos interlocuteurs
et bien sûr les associations qui jouent
un rôle crucial de soutien aux familles
une meilleure coordination une plus
grande visibilité des différentes
initiatives et structures sont cependant
nécessaire malheureusement il ne nous
est pas possible de nous rendre dans
tous les territoires d'outre-mer
donc la visioconférence que nous offre
cette possibilité d'échanges nous nous
réjouissons donc de pouvoir ainsi
échanger cet après-midi avec les acteurs
de la Guyane merci à vous pour cette
visioconférence
pour nous aider à appréhender la
situation particulière de la Guyane que
nous allons maintenant aborder nous
allons entendre par visioconférence des
acteurs très engagés que nous remercions
vivement pour leur disponibilité sachant
qu'il y a plus de 5 heures de décalage
par rapport à nos amis à Cayenne donc
pour la collectivité de territoriale
madame Aïssatou Chambon vice-présidente
présidente de la Fabrègues Fédération
autonome des parents d'élèves et
étudiants de Guyane pour la direction
régionale au droit des femmes et à
l'égalité madame Isabelle hiverkowski
directrice pour la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales Madame Anne
Sina pierre Charles directrice par
intérim qui est accompagnée de Madame
Mario chandeli directrice adjointe par
intérim madame est Soliman responsable
du développement social et Monsieur
Olivier Noguerra responsable de l'accès
aux droits et de l'accompagnement des
familles pour le réseau périnat et
Guyane madame Aline Talbot chargée de
projet et grande grossesse adolescente
mesdames messieurs vous avez été
destinataires d'une trame de questions
pour vous propose-liminaires ont vu
d'une présentation d'une dizaine de
minutes environ puis les rapporteurs
vous poseront des questions sur les
points qu'ils souhaitent approfondir et
enfin ce sera le tour de nos autres
collègues que je salue au passage en
présentiel et en distanciel je ne serai
pas plus long pour laisser le maximum de
temps de parole aux intervenants et à
nos collègues je vous remercie et je
vous propose de commencer dans l'ordre
que j'ai énoncé donc par la collectivité
territoriale
[Musique]
bonjour à tous
elle s'attache en gros effectivement à
la collectivité territoriale de Guyane
et président de l'attrapeg également
donc
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une partie
présentation mais on va faire l'économie
qu'on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet vu
le temps imparti donc sur la première
partie concernant la spécificité
familiales et parentale ce que nous
avons dénoté c'est qu'il y a quand même
des solidarités familiales qui sont très
présentes alors je parlerai pour ma part
plus particulièrement de la société de
la communauté créole que je maîtrise
mieux et Madame Christy c'est complétera
je suppose
parce que ce qu'on a noté également au
niveau de la rapelle et de la
collectivité c'est qu'il y a un regard
stigmatisant sur les P1
d'où le fait que on parle de maglin
désengagement qui peut paraître apparent
au niveau des pères au niveau des papas
il existe tout de même une
organisation familiale qui est portée
par la mer puisqu'on est dans une
société focale et au niveau des
grands-parents on note aussi qu'ils
jouent pleinement leur rôle au sein de
l'organisation et contribue à
l'éducation des enfants alors c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas mis l'action sur les
forcément sur les difficultés ou les
problèmes on a souhaité avoir porté ce
regard sur ce qui fonctionne au niveau
des familles
que dans le dans le coin qu'on nous a
transmis il y a quand même pas mal de
difficultés qui sont relatives donc
cette solidarité familiale elle se
manifeste lorsqu'il est question de
s'occupait des enfants mais aussi des
aînés donc des grands-parents concernant
les grands-parents
la note la norme reste le maintien à
domicile le placement n'est pas une
intervient vraiment en dernier recours
lorsqu'il n'y a plus possibilité de pour
le parent et dans l'enfance souvent de
s'occuper de son parent par rapport à la
fatigue habilité
par lorsque
l'état de santé de
de la personne âgée s'est dégradée quand
elle nécessite vraiment beaucoup de
soins mais en tout cas là non mais le
maintien à domicile
veut dire de plus ah oui pour en revenir
au Père donc j'ai quand même interrogé
et à échanger avec quelques papas
qui
disent qu'ils se sentent mis à l'écart
au niveau de la parentalité au niveau de
leur rôle de père mais plus
particulièrement lorsqu'il y a des
difficultés dans le couple lorsque des
problèmes de garde d'enfant se posent
pour ce que j'ai interrogé ils sont dans
l'incapacité de voir leurs enfants parce
que la maman est en conflit avec la
maman elles n'ont pas ils sont privés de
jouer leur rôle de père et quand il
saisissent la justice
en tout cas ce qu'il en ressort c'est
que ils se sentent alors c'est vraiment
ressentir je n'ai pas de données chiffré
ou factuel
ils se sentent ne se sont pas
accompagnés au même titre que les mamans
dans le sens où ils soient ils n'ont pas
de réponse soit il y a des réponses qui
leur conviennent pas ou qui sont très
fameux en faveur de la main mais pour ce
que j'ai interrogé souvent il n'y a pas
de réponse
je poursuis sur les
comment on procède parce qu'on pouvait
continuer effectivement vous pouvez
aller au travers de
préciser les choses sur le questionnaire
qui vous a été envoyé effectivement
je suis la trame de vos questions
voilà c'est ça si vous voulez vous
pouvez regarder et puis après il y a la
trame des questions
sur laquelle chacun d'entre vous pourra
revenir et puis surtout on souhaiterait
un support écrit
aux questions qui vous ont adressées ce
qui sera plus simple ce qui fait que
vous pouvez évoquer en audition des
choses que vous n'avez pas forcément
évoqué dans le support écrit
s
complémentaires et voilà ma proposition
est que nous puissions intervenir pour
chaque entité sur chacune des questions
aucun problème aucun problème
très bien
[Musique]
du coup du coup puisque j'ai la parole
je me permets donc de quelques propos
liminaires très rapidement
mesdames messieurs présidents sénatrice
sénateur mesdames et messieurs en vous
grade et qualité bien sûr nous vous
remercions de d'avoir invité la CAF à
cette table ronde puisque la parentalité
est une thématique forte chez nous
alors il était prévu que j'ai que j'ai
lancé quelques éléments de contexte sur
la Guyane mais les éléments qu'a donné
donc Madame billon Vienne voilà
comment dire enrichir enrichir le propos
de
contextualisation et me dire quand même
effectivement même si la Guyane n'est
pas à présenter voilà la fenêtre dans
les lignes et la vivre sont dedans
[Musique]
75 fois la Martinique en taille avec un
défaut d'accessibilité certain et une
densité très très faible en majorité sur
le terrain une couverture de réseau
Internet qui est partielle et régulière
tout cela rentre l'accès à l'information
et au droit assez complexe c'est pour
éviter natalité avec des douzaines une
bonne douzaine donc d'écoles collèges
lycée qui ouvre parents
une pluralité de communauté
une pluralité évidemment de langue de
culture voici encore d'autres
caractéristiques qui nous amènent la CAF
à vouloir développer des actions de
proximité une politique d'aller vers une
politique d'expérimentation pour nous la
Guyane est un laboratoire dans le sens
noble du terme temps
l'aspectation
le caractère d'innovation sont de mises
et donc forment aussi nos postures
résoluments donc sur la parentalité
nous allons poursuivre sur la question
une puisque le temps le temps file
donc ce que je propose non pour aller
sur la question une madame
Christie juste après que Madame
chandelli et annoncé quand même quelques
constats CAF sur sur la
des grands-parents
parents et autrement un ami Béatrice
pour apprendre le pour apposer son
regard d'anthropologue je vous remercie
pour votre attention merci Madame la
Directrice monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs gradicalité bonjour à
tous En effet donc un constat très très
marqué en ce qui concerne la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales regarde notre
fichier donc
peut-être pas grand chose à découvrir
mais en tout cas nécessité de de le
préciser une jeunesse des parents
de fait des grands-parents encore en
activité et encore jeune violemment et
en âge d'être en activité donc rend
difficile la relation un noyau salmonial
qui est comme le disait je crois madame
la Présidente un peu plus large que ce
que l'on constater au niveau de la
métropole et des Antilles
et puis le statut particulier qui est
marqué
comme étant quelque chose d'acquis dans
notre société via la maternité et puis
aussi également des grands-parents
souvent là aussi je crois que Madame la
vice-présidente l'avait déjà souligné
qui souvent dans ce substitut aux
parents et
également pour accompagner les parents
de leur rôle de Paris
voilà le constat que nous faisons nous
aujourd'hui au regard des populations en
tout cas des familles à locataires que
la CAF se promener
donc comme indiqué par
la directrice nous le sont le soin à
madame Isabelle Christy verbe compléter
ces éléments avec son regard de
professionnel anthropologue
merci
oui bonjour
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs sénatrice bonjour à toutes
bonjour à tous alors effectivement j'ai
deux casquettes parce que je suis
présenté comme directrice régionale au
droit des femmes et puis de temps en
temps comme anthropologue en fait je
suis professeur des universités en
anthropologie mise à disposition par
l'Université de Guyane à la préfecture
depuis quatre ans en qualité de
directrice régionale au droit des femmes
et je peux dire que les deux fonctions
sont véritablement complémentaires parce
que lorsqu'on parle des familles en
Guyane on parle aussi beaucoup de
problèmes des femmes en Guyane parce que
bien souvent les familles reposent sur
les femmes alors il faut savoir qu'on
est dans une situation particulière en
Guyane ou les femmes qui représentent
plus de la moitié de la population c'est
51% de la population guyanaise la 57%
d'entre elles n'ont pas de diplôme donc
c'est lié à l'histoire de la Guyane mais
pas seulement qu'une histoire migratoire
c'est qu'on retrouve aussi parmi les
populations nées en Guyane et
autochtones des populations des familles
non francophones donc la non
francophonie ne concerne pas uniquement
les populations étrangères en Guyane
donc on peut être français les Français
autochtones et non francophones donc ça
peut montrer aussi de très grandes
difficultés au sein des familles qui
sont pourtant
issus du territoire guyanais de manière
ancestrale donc
57%, c'est comme 77% de ces femmes sont
un diplôme 11% des femmes de Guyane qui
ont plus de 30 ans ne sont pas
titulaires du baccalauréat donc ces
éléments vont avoir des incidences
directes sur l'emploi l'accès à l'emploi
et le bien-être des familles parce que
on a un taux de chômage régional de 44%
Thomas de chômage régional des femmes
qui est le plus élevé de toutes les
régions de France alors conséquence et
on va se retrouver avec des familles en
plus grandes difficultés en plus grande
précarité ou souvent l'éducation et les
liens de parenté sont difficiles à
entretenir et la transmission se fait
dans des conditions extrêmement
compliquées alors la famille en Guyane
est fortement liée à la scolarité
c'est-à-dire la réussite scolaire va
dépendre aussi de la réussite
professionnelle de la famille et donc
des femmes comme je viens de le dire
donc là dessus si vous voulez que je
développe plus on peut continuer ou
sinon je garde les éléments d'analyse
pour les autres points parce qu'en
réalité les différentes questions que
nous allons aborder sont intrinsèquement
liés et une aux autres et explique le
profil des familles et des liens de
parenté en Guyane donc voilà pour le
tableau général pour moi il y a vraiment
ce lien à faire entre situation des
femmes en Guyane qui va expliquer aussi
après la question des familles la
structure familiale des liens de parenté
et de l'éducation
vous me dites si vous voulez que je
poursuivre sur les autres points je
pense qu'à ce stade on peut peut-être
passer la parole à Madame alintalbot
pour faire un tour d'horizon déjà un
premier tour d'horizon
avec l'ensemble des acteurs
bonjour bonjour tout le monde merci pour
cette opportunité que nous avons
justement vous faire voir la réalité du
terrain donc moi je suis Madame Calvo
Aline encore donatrice et du projet
grossesse
des grossesse adolescentes un long et un
large
ou si vous le permettez madame idéal
Crousty sur les questions une et deux
voilà c'était plus votre votre champ
dans la mesure où vous êtes dans la même
pièce
et vous vous êtes coordonnées on vous
laisse le soin de passer au travers du
questionnaire avec votre organisation il
y a aucune difficulté
très bien merci
nous avons diminué d'intervention
parentité donc vous vous interviendrez
sur les questions une deux et cinq
merci oui alors ben je poursuis du coup
donc maintenant il faut examiner pour
comprendre la situation des familles
faut véritablement examiner aussi au
regard de la géographie de l'histoire de
la Guyane donc là aussi on a déjà un
contexte particulier lorsqu'on parle des
Outre-mer on a vraiment un cas
particulier qui est celui de la Guyane
parce que nous ne sommes pas insulaires
et on retrouve en Guyane une histoire
particulière entre le littoral il faut
bien distinguer le littoral et
l'intérieur du pays et ça c'est
difficile cette division cette coupure
véritablement deux de la Guyane et
historique et elle a eu des conséquences
directes sur la scolarité l'histoire de
la scolarisation et sur la vie un impact
considérable sur le niveau économique et
la vie des familles en Guyane alors le
littoral jusqu'à la départementalisation
en fait on voit que seul le littoral est
véritablement concerné par la
scolarisation donc dès l'abolition de
l'esclavage jusqu'en 1948 ce sont
surtout les enfants descendants
d'esclaves du littoral qui vont être
scolarisés à partir de 1948 avec la
départementalisation voie 1950 arrivée
les premières écoles et pensionnats
catholiques à l'intérieur du pays pour
scolariser les populations amérindiennes
et noir marron qui représente la
majorité de la population de l'Intérieur
à cette époque donc on va voir une
différence considérable de niveau de vie
et d'organisation familiale entre les
populations de du littoral jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on va voir que le littoral
est mieux doté en matière scolaire et
pourtant il est en retard lui-même avec
des difficultés liées à la croissance
démographique et l'intérieur du pays
qui a pris considérablement du retard en
matière d'infrastructures infrastructure
routière mais aussi infrastructures
scolaire pourtant la croissance
démographique qui est très importante
alors les élèves qui sont scolarisés à
l'intérieur du pays voir de fait un
retard scolaire et on va retrouver plein
taux de chômage des jeunes beaucoup plus
important on va retrouver du décrochage
scolaire aussi en nombre plus importants
donc on voit bien que à l'intérieur de
la Guyane c'est c'est pas homogène parce
que lorsqu'on se rapproche et qu'on
compare les différentes régions
guyanaise et bien on va voir qu'en
fonction de l'intérieur ou du littoral
les chiffres seront totalement
différents donc là il faudra être
justement vigilant parce que
l'organisation familiale elle aussi elle
est différente c'est les populations du
littoral ont adopté avec la politique de
l'assimilation justement liée à la
scolarisation ces populations vont
adopter le mode de vie occidental plutôt
que celle de l'Intérieur celle de
l'Intérieur ont encore ce mode de vie
au clan et aux lignages alors c'est là
qu'on va retrouver les questions liées à
la monoparentalité qui souvent sont
confondus parce que dans les clans il y
a des lignages matrilinéaires c'est la
mère qui a en charge les enfants le Père
ne n'a pas le droit c'est totalement
interdit de se mêler de l'éducation de
ses enfants alors lorsque j'interviens
avec mes collègues de l'Insee qui font
des recensements sur le terrain on se
rend bien compte que les questions
posées au maire et aux familles c'est
avec qui vivez-vous sous votre toit qui
vit avec vous ben je viens seul avec mes
enfants donc votre mari n'est pas là non
et je vis seul avec mes enfants résultat
en attendant ça
augmenter de manière artificielle les
chiffres de liés à la monoparentalité
qu'il faut absolument corriger parce
qu'on n'a pas une monoparentalité en
fait elle est multiforme on n'a pas une
majorité de personnes de femmes qui sont
en situation d'isolement de côté et
vraiment livré à elle-même seule avec
leurs enfants ça va représenter un très
faible pourcentage dans cet ensemble la
majorité des familles monoparentales en
Guyane sont reliées toujours
systématiquement à une famille élargie
donc avec la présence des collatéraux et
c'est là qu'on va retrouver justement
c'est liens cette collaboration
cette entraide entre la différentes
générations qui encore bien dynamique
sur l'autre territoire qu'il faut
absolument conserver parce que lorsque
nous avons des jeunes qui vont
s'installer de tout en restant Guyane et
qui vont s'installer dans d'autres
régions quitter l'intérieur pour aller
sur le littoral et bien le littoral pour
eux c'est un pays totalement étranger
qu'il ne maîtrise pas qu'ils ne
connaissent pas et ils pourront mieux
s'insérer si ils ont des parents déjà
installés donc c'est pour revenir à la
question de la scolarisation c'est elle
a eu un impact considérable sur la
réussite
cette géographie parce que lorsque les
écoles n'étaient pas les infrastructures
n'étaient pas présentes à proximité du
domicile et bien les enfants étaient
d'office inscrits dans des pensionnats
catholiques alors c'est pensionnats
existent encore parce que toute la
Guyane n'est pas doté pourvu
d'équipement scolaires donc on va se
retrouver dans des zones géographiques
ou ben après le collège je dois partir
au même après le l'école primaire je
dois quitter ma famille pour m'inscrire
au collège à plusieurs kilomètres de la
maison du domicile où je termine le
collège et au lycée je dois partir pour
m'inscrire au lycée à plusieurs
kilomètres éloignés du domicile alors
cette particularité en Guyane pose de
véritables de l'organisation des
familles et la réussite scolaire
lorsqu'on a 11 ans lorsqu'on a 15 ans on
est encore très jeune et souvent en
proie à différentes tentations s'il y a
pas le contrôle parental l'or
l'accompagnement de ces jeunes alors moi
je retrouve par exemple beaucoup de
jeunes filles qui sont agressées
sexuellement ou d'autres encore qui vont
se traire facilement ça a donné à la
consommation de substances psychoactives
parce qu'il rentre dans des phases de
dépression et puis d'autres enquêtes
aussi que je mène sur les réseaux de
suicide plus importants à l'intérieur de
la Guyane que sur le littoral chez nos
jeunes donc on a tout un enchaînement de
conséquences liées à la géographie de la
Guyane à la scolarisation de nos enfants
et aux liens familiaux qui sont
distendus du fait justement de
l'éloignement géographique alors qu'on
n'a pas encore quitté la Guyane alors
lorsqu'on quitte la Guyane beaucoup de
jeunes sont amenés à faire à suivre une
carrière professionnelle à l'extérieur
mais il peut y avoir des conséquences
encore plus dramatiques ça je
l'aborderai pas c'est dans notre sujet
pour un débat plus tard
sur la question du coup de la
l'organisation familiale et de la
monoparentalité pour venir sur ces
questions et bien elle est souvent liée
bien souvent liée à une volonté pour les
jeunes filles que nous allons rencontrer
une volonté finalement d'exister on va
retrouver plusieurs raisons et l'une de
ces raisons ça va être l'envie d'exister
dans ce dispositif qui est assez violent
d'une certaine manière ou il y a pas
beaucoup de propositions qui sont faites
à l'emploi pour les femmes donc peu
d'emploi plus de propositions et puis
des jeunes filles qui n'ont pas de
bagages scolaire suffisant pour trouver
une situation professionnelle qui
permettrait une autonomie financière
donc bien souvent elles sont maman alors
qu'elles sont encore adolescentes et les
enfants vont être pris en charge par les
grands-mères voire même par les arrières
grands-mères puisqu'on les générations
il y a souvent très peu d'écart d'âge
donc la maternité à ce moment là pour
certaines va devenir comme une forme
d'occupation où on a d'autres cas de
figure heureusement moins importants
mais d'autres cas de figure ou la
maternité va arriver à la suite d'abus
sexuel ça il faut aussi le souligner
sans parler après alors j'ai mentionné
le fait que des jeunes filles devaient
quitter leur domicile pour être
scolarisé à des kilomètres plus loin et
là on va se retrouver
avec des situations de prostitution donc
on nous abordons en ce moment même dans
la commission départementale de parcours
de sortie de prostitution et installer
par Monsieur le Préfet ces questions
justement liées à la prostitution de nos
jeunes parce que il est difficile pour
eux de comprendre et là il y a une
sensibilisation importante à faire on a
des jeunes femmes qui ont des
difficultés à comprendre que le fait
d'échanger des prestations
contre un téléphone portable
le tour en scooter ou bien 20 euros
c'est de la prostitution mais on a
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont des
difficultés à faire la part des choses à
comprendre et qui parfois bien souvent
en quittant le domicile et je terminerai
sur ces aspects là aussi qui sont
difficiles à contrôler en Guyane c'est
qu'on a souvent des jeunes qui n'ont
plus sont plus sous le contrôle de la
famille élargie et en quittant le
domicile vont faire connaissance avec
les réseaux sociaux ou une bonne partie
de la Guyane a des difficultés de
connexion et une fois que on se
rapproche du littoral et bien on va
avoir accès au téléphone portable et aux
réseaux sociaux plus facilement sans
forcément avoir été éduqué sans
forcément avoir appris à utiliser ces
nouveaux outils alors en Guyane en
fonction des zones géographiques et je
conclurai sur cette particularité mais
en fonction des zones géographiques il y
a des Guyane auquel on doit s'adapter et
tous les dispositifs qui sont proposés
au niveau national et bien on ne les
décline pas de la même façon partout en
Guy ane on s'adapte non seulement aux
langues parce que nous avons aussi 4% de
nos élèves qui ne sont pas francophones
donc on adapte nos dispositifs aux
langues parlées en Guyane dont 10 sont
des reconnus comme langue régionale on
adapte nos dispositifs aussi aux
différentes cultures et conception du
monde présente en Guyane je vous
remercie
nous pouvons poursuivre sur
sur la partie grossesse précoce
merci et donc Madame Talbot intervenu à
la fois sur la question 4 mais plusieurs
d'entre elles pour pour rester dans le
timing que vous nous avez
consenti merci énormément madame hidder
effectivement sur le terrain on est
appelé des fois à travailler ensemble
elle a bien posé le cadre moi je vais
continuer je vais poser une définition
quand même alors les grossesse précoce
c'est une grossesse qui survient avant
l'âge de 20 ans de la maman donc en
Guyane on a 1300 grossesse adolescentes
et nous en réseau vers une natalité on
accompagne 240 par an donc les
problématiques on va y arriver pour vous
montrer réellement dans quel contexte on
intervient d'un des situations qu'on est
confrontés avant avant tout ça je vais
vous parler de l'étiologie des
grossesses précoces in Guyane qui relève
d'un problème
spectacle profond parce que chaque
situation comme l'année dernière vient
poser et particulièrement
différent et à une histoire différente
que nous on prend le temps de recueillir
de prendre en considération et
d'accompagner donc les grossesses
adolescentes semblent beaucoup en grande
majorité peut désirer alors les
motivations elle a bien elle a bien
souligné c'est le désir de trouver de la
féminité chez quelqu'un qui est jeune le
désir de s'émanciper également on a des
jeunes qui veulent s'émanciper quitter
la famille le désir d'exister le désir
naturel de maternité de se reproduire
nos désirs de trouver son indépendance à
ses parents mais également implicitement
ça je le vois également sur le terrain
se lancer un cri d'alarme un signal de
détresse
souvent les jeunes sont laissés à
elle-même comme elle a bien mentionné à
des jeunes qui quittent le l'intérieur
pour venir son Cayenne et pour les
études elle se retrouve seule dans leur
appartement sans parents isolés de leur
communauté et il y a un jeune homme qui
est la plus puissante et les jeunes
rencontres sur les réseaux sociaux et
puis elles sont maintenant couple et il
y a un enfant qui vient alors les
raisons qui poussent des jeunes
porter des enfants très tôt ici un duels
qu'on observe en tout cas ils sont les
réseaux sont à la fois sociologiques
sociaux culturelles et psychosocial
alors du coup conscient ou être
conscient c'est un élément qui est on
constate sur le terrain chez ladou la
grossesse est parfois des manques et des
carences affectifs précoces alors
certaines adolescentes peut entourer et
les recherches systématiquement la
tendresse l'amour vers à travers les
sexualité dont elles ne comprennent ni
usage ni vice cachés alors je vous donne
un exemple d'une jeune 13 ans
qui était enfant qui est en couple avec
son copain de 15 ans les deux décident
de faire un enfant
alors on a été invité à intervenir très
tôt à la découverte de la grossesse et
nos parents étaient totalement désemparé
un parrain hyper impliqué dans le suivi
de sa fille nous on a rencontré la jeune
à part seule elle nous explique que elle
cherche son terme parce que les parents
sont séparés elle a pas de lien de
proximité d'affection avec son père elle
nous fait comprendre que son père lui
manque et du coup pour elle les
compensations c'est la sexualité son
copain il est toujours présent elle peut
compter sur lui même elle a traversé des
situations tellement difficiles parce
que la maman
là voulait qu'elle avorte la énormément
accompagné pour un avortement mais
malheureusement la grossesse était déjà
avancée et la jeune a fait exprès de la
pensée
ça c'est parce qu'elle voulait garder
son nom donc ce sont des réalités il y a
une situation qui qui me dit rapidement
en tête la jeune
à la saison
et
son père apprend qu'elle a commencé à
avoir des relations sexuelles le papa la
prend et la met la
laine dans en dehors de la famille en
dehors de la ville dans la forêt la
tellement tabassé au point où elle est
restée à la maison pendant 5 jours parce
que elle a eu des rapports sexuels et
quand nous exprime madame je cherchais
mon père aussi parce qu'on perdait de se
séparer de sa manger mon père me
maquillage
et la question qu'on lui a posé ce
qu'elle est cool on réduit ton appétit
qu'on appétence de la sexualité
elle nous a dit non je me suis donné à
fond dans la sexualité et même à un
moment donné nous rapporte que elle a pu
elle a été elle a prévu des viols
collectif
ce sont des situations nous qu'on écoute
on essaie de compatir on essaie
d'accompagner c'est d'orienter avec au
cours des partenaires qui existent
dans la vie
complètement perdus démunies à avoir
désemparés elles sont confondues à La
galère du quotidien aussi le rejet des
parents le rejet de
l'éducation aussi de l'école
un exemple simple des fois qu'on fait
des équipes éducatives pour trouver des
solutions pour la scolarité
la plupart même des professionnels qui
sont à l'éducation nationale sont c'est
tellement violent qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à adopter une posture professionnelle
compatissante envers ses adolescents
c'est les réalités nous en réseau permet
d'être quand on méfait aujourd'hui
d'être la personne qui va essayer de
recadrer un peu quelques professionnels
pour qu'on reste justement dans dans la
bienveillance parce que ces jeunes sont
vraiment très démunis
parce que je vous ai pas citer les
statistiques pour les connaissez j'ai
suivi les différentes études menées donc
la Guyane vous prenez c'est le tableau
mais rapidement en tout cas ici dans au
réseau périnée à 20 % des collégiens
qu'ils sont des scolarisés donc le
collège c'est même pas le lycée 20% de
nos accompagnements des collégiens des
jeunes ont moins de 15 ans sont
déscolarisés
je continue donc du coup les maternités
chez les adolescents en Guyane en tout
cas comme on dit c'est un facteur qui
c'est la conséquence de la précarité de
la pauvreté de la mauvaise maîtrise ou
l'absence de la contraception le refa
faible niveau d'éducation l'inégalité
entre les sexes aussi et certaines
normes et actives communautaires et les
grossesses adolescentes présents des
risques médicaux et là je vais vraiment
essayer de souligner ça des risques
médicaux sociaux et psychologiques très
important au niveau des risques médicaux
il y a la longueur de la jeune c'est
elle parle qu'on n'est pas assez mature
qui portait la grossesse et les risques
médicaux peuvent être très important
notamment les naissances prématurées les
jeunes qui font pas suivre leur
grossesse parce que pour elle c'est pas
une priorité la l'enfant Kélo la jeune
porte il y a pas le lien déjà dans la
dans
dans le ventre c'est comme si bon je
découvre quelque chose que je ne
maîtrise pas également donc l'impact
social nous voyons des risques comme je
viens de le mentionner il y a la grande
pauvreté la déscolarisation la
prostitution modalités pour souvenirs
aux besoins de leurs enfants et de leurs
besoins aussi les moments des jeunes il
y a des hommes associés il y a la
difficulté d'établir le lien
mère-enfants les impacts sur la santé de
l'enfant et les jeunes sont les jeunes
filles sont les plus impactés par les
maternités précoces que les garçons du
même âge ce qui contribue également à
renforcer les inégalités de genre dans
notre société c'est des éléments qu'on
rencontre
malheureusement la jeune va abandonner
l'école parce que à la personne pour
garder son enfant on a des cas comme ça
et parce que s'il y a l'isolement les
parents sont dans un autre pays la jeune
issue de l'immigration elle arrive ici
toute seule elle est enceinte elle
accouche il y a pas de communauté autour
et elle est obligée d'abandonner l'école
parce qu'à la personne pour garder son
enfant et elle a pas les moyens pour
payer le cerveau bien
donc il y a les impacts aussi
psychologiques qu'on a beaucoup relevés
à la déco de la grossesse et la santé
mentale de la jeune prend en
forme souvent les rapports sexuels
ne sont pas consentis il y a des
violences sexuelles nous nos
accompagnements on a plus de 10% de nos
accompagnements ou les jeunes ont été
abusé sexuellement et les plans des
enfants
issus de viol elles ont décidé de garder
les grossesses malgré que c'est c'est
des violences sexuelles donc elle a
grossesse n'est pas du tout planifiée
donc les viols ils vivent c'est des
risques aussi les jeunes prennent des
risques et
comme enceinte sans être planifié la
jeune ne s'imagine pas devenir maman son
âge à 13 ans 12 ans on imagine pas
devenir maman donc la prière de le suivi
de la grossesse et les souffrances
mentale est très observée on rencontre
la honte le reprise sur soi et délivre
la culpabilité qui fragilise beaucoup la
santé mentale et la culpabilité aussi de
l'entourage les parents qui nous
soutiennent pas qui vont culpabiliser un
processus et ça ça conduit à des idées à
Sciences suicidaires on a bien dit aussi
la plupart des jeunes s'orientés
rapidement vers les psychologues et du
CNV ado les psychologues de l'hôpital
pour un suivi psychologique parce que
leur santé mentale est très touché
et le soutient là du coup non rôle c'est
vraiment mobiliser le soutien de
l'entourage parce que il jeune qui est
bien entouré par sa famille va traverser
cette grossesse tranquille sans problème
qui me gêne qui est isolé sans soutien
de sa famille donc les jeunes filles qui
ont suivi des agressions sexuelles bon
comme je viens de le dire le suivi
psychologique s'avère indispensable je
me rappelle que cette jeune qui est
venue me voir abusé par son père je vais
essayer de le dire simplement et elle me
dit Madame Talbot je pense que j'ai mon
enfant c'est mon père il faut que je
fasse un crise de fraternité
effectivement c'était c'est difficile de
d'entendre des propos comme ça oui mon
père il a été serré et heureusement
d'ailleurs il est en prison donc la
jeune elle est vue avec cet enfant qui
allait pouvoir qui représente le viol de
son père et ça c'est un cas au moment où
nos papaye en prison on a d'autres
situations malheureusement les jeunes
sont violés et les violeurs sont
toujours
sont toujours autour de la gel qui a
peint il y a aussi cette problématique
de la justice
ou bon voilà il y a des situations comme
ça qui arrivent
donc
du coup pour comment aider comment aider
nous on essaie d'accompagner le mieux ça
c'est des chiffres internes que on est
entre deux roues ici
il y a des chiffres rapidement pour vous
donner quelques chiffres nous avons 50%
à l'ouest des jeunes qui sont français
donc il y a 50% d'objets qui sont pas
français nous avons 80% de ces jeunes
qui sont des scolarisés parmi les 240
jeunes filles qu'on accompagne donc on a
dit à 5% l'Ouest sont les sites de viol
et 35% suivi des violences et ça c'est
aussi un effet c'est la même chose à
l'Est nous les jeunes vivent énormément
de violence que ça soit les parents
l'entourage ils sont elles sont
confrontées à des violences
alors je vais rapidement je voulais vous
parler des problématiques mais je pense
pas que j'ai le temps mais je vais y
arriver
ok super alors les problématiques comme
je l'ai bien mentionné c'est l'extrême
précarité matérielle psychologique de
ces jeunes il y a l'absence de troubles
de naissance pour la maternité c'est la
réalité logement insalubre sans eau
électricité pour la plupart de
nourriture personnellement des jeunes
qui mettaient madame est-ce que je peux
avoir un produit alimentaire je mange
quoi elle est enceinte des fois on est
obligé d'aller courir les CCAS pour
pouvoir
pour pouvoir avoir des colliers
alimentaires aujourd'hui à Guyane le
seul
je dirais partenaire qui donnait aux
frais rapidement facilement les
premières alimentaires qui est la Croix
Rouge
à comment dire céder ses missions au
CCAS qui était déjà débordée dans cette
distribution des colis alimentaires donc
on a des jeunes qui n'ont rien à manger
elles sont enceintes
donc on a des je voulais aussi vous
donner un exemple d'une jeune récemment
qui a 15 ans enceinte de 6 mois qui vit
dans une chambre qu'elle est partage
avec sa mère et ses trois frères et
sœurs la jeune n’est pas scolarisée son
établissement scolaire se trouve à
réunir mon joli à la vie de son Cayenne
donc du coup elle marche pour arriver à
mon joli c'est connaissent un peu la
Guyane c'est quasi impossible elle a pas
les moyens pour se payer le bus et la
abandonner l'école aujourd'hui la mère
m'a regardé droit dans les yeux m'a dit
Madame
on visite la petite chambre on va
cette maman elle est la situation
régulière c'est pas une maman qui n'a
pas le cas de séjour mais elle a fait un
renouvellement on lui donne des récepts
ça fait plus dormi qu'elle reçoit des
récepticés de trois mois avec ces
récépissés de trois mois la mère ne peut
pas faire valoir ses droits aux
allocations familiales elle ne peut pas
travailler et cette situation la plongée
dans une grande précarité alors qu'elle
s'occupe de sa fille qui enseigne qui a
4 15 ans sa fille consomme du quali elle
a sa petite sa loterie qui a 14 ans qui
est aussi consomme du cavi la mère me
regarde des fois j'étais mon enfant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place bon
voilà donc il y a des problématiques il
y a aussi des cassures avec la famille
il y a le déclencheur de décrochage
scolaire je vais vite et la garde
d'enfants comme je l'ai dit l'isolement
social alors rapidement il y a des trucs
de comportement c'est déjà écrit
rapidement parce qu'il ne reste que un
quart d'heure et on voudrait pouvoir
couvrir notamment le champ des
politiques familiales et prestations
les préconisations aujourd'hui aux
légumes référentes grossesse adolescent
es en Guyane sur 1300 grossesses ados
c'est pas du tout assez avec les
problématiques qu'on rencontre donc ils
nous ont 4
donc il y a des créations des postes
parentalités pour soutenir les jeunes
après l'accouchement parce que il y a
des jeunes après un mois après la sortie
de l'hôpital tout ce qui est écran des
jeunes montrent les dessins animés à ses
enfants à la sortie de l'hôpital
les jeunes le sapeur comment nourrir
leurs bébés parce que c'est des jeunes
eux aussi qui sont perdus et aujourd'hui
je lance un cri d'alarme même je l'ai
déjà lancé depuis longtemps
qui veulent non assistante en personne
en danger c'est des bébés qu'il faut des
bébés et on ne les accompagne pas après
la naissance je vous remercie énormément
et un seul paternel aussi qui manque
régulière donc vous connaissez déjà donc
tout le monde serait au courant donc je
vous remercie énormément pour de m'avoir
écouté et voilà
nous proposons de poursuivre avec
justement les politiques familiales et
donc les prestations madame solemann
va prendre le flambeau merci Madame la
Directrice monsieur président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs à l'ensemble des
participants
vont justement
très rapidement effectivement les
politiques sociales et familiales sont
interfaces de nombreuses politiques sur
le territoire politique de santé
politique sociale d'insertion de
prévention et ce que mon insert c'est
qu'il existe université d'acteurs et le
projet sur le territoire il existe une
diversité de plans le plan de lutte
contre la pauvreté les schémas
territoriaux des services aux familles
et de l'action sociale de proximité
enfin nous avons une grande liste qui
nous amène à questionner en fait la
question de la coordination on y
reviendra plus
tard ce que l'on note c'est que sur le
thème toi les projets en direction des
familles et de la parentale et sont
portées après de 80% par des
associations ce portage c'est un atout
c'est un constate un atout parce que
cela permet un maillage sur le
territoire être au plus près des
populations mais effectivement l'enjeu
majeur c'est bien celui de la
coordination de ces acteurs de leur
décloisonnement de la mise en réseau des
partenaires et des actions alors au
titre du film national d'action sociale
qui est donc en fond de la hanche aux
familles sur le territoire sont près de
24 millions qui sont dédiés annuellement
au service aux familles alors un client
bien évidemment la petite enfance la
jeunesse mais si on observe et si on
fait une focale et spécifique sur la
parentalité on est après de 1 million
500 000 euros à l'élève dédié fléchés
sur des projets et des actions
parentalité
que l'on observer en tout cas au travers
de ces données là c'est qu'en termes de
dispositif celui qui est mobilisé la
majoritairement c'est le réseau d'écoute
et d'accompagnement à la parentalité
on a aussi le contrat local
d'accompagnement à la scolarité mais de
manière plus minoritaire et
effectivement les projets d'envergure
tels que la médiation familiale les
espaces rencontrent les lieux
d'accueil-en-parents mais aussi
l'accueil de la petite enfance qui
permet de socialiser de travailler le
lien par enfant ce sont des comment dire
des services des projets qui nécessitent
professionnels sur le territoire qui
nécessite des moyens
économiques comment dire
de manière pérenne les services là en
direction des populations et c'est tout
le travail effectivement que l'on fait
aujourd'hui mais qui est à renforcer
fortement à notre sens
alors moi je vais pas être vendre au
comment dire on va aussi aborder
peut-être la question de la formation
c'est ce que je disais la compétence
alors voilà pour développer des services
aux familles et des actions parentalités
oui les techniciens de l'intendance
sociale et familiale
de vie aussi cela ne manque cruellement
la question des travailleurs sociaux des
personnes qui sont en capacité de porter
de l'ingénierie de projet en fait ce
domaine là pour nous et assez comment
dire prioritaire en ce sens qu'il permet
justement la structure et la mise en
place dans le temps de tous ces services
là et en fait nous avons des pépites
puisque sur le territoire nous avons une
jeunesse en tout cas on tourne voilà un
vivier en fait il faut que l'on
accompagne et que le porte pour que
justement il soit demain eux en action
sur le territoire pour ses services là
voilà
nous avons
identifié différentes en tout cas
différents besoins
balayer très rapidement ce mode de
coordination donc je peux parler en
termes de synergie entre les acteurs et
le manque de visibilité donc des acteurs
qui interviennent dans le champ de la
parentalité
un sillage qui n'est pas spécifique sur
certaines actions au risque de passer à
côté de certains besoins donc cette
méconnaissance des acteurs dans la vie
des projets cloisonnés ce que l'on
propose en tout cas collectivement c'est
qu'il puisse y avoir des nations en tout
cas les identification d'un chef de fil
de la parentalité
pouvoir développer justement cette
coordination territoriale dédiée à la
parentalité avec la les emplois en
charge des munition parentalité
ce qu'il faut savoir
des services aux familles mais la
question d'ingénierie reste centrale et
c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui une des
difficultés que l'on rencontre cela se
mette en mode opérationnel ce que l'on
souhaite aussi créer mettre en place des
dispositifs dédiés donc à la
coordination accompagnement individuelle
des familles et des enfants mais aussi
les financements associés c'est
qu'aujourd'hui au de là en tout cas
politique familiale en famille on
intervient majoritairement sur des
services collectifs c'est vrai que
l'approche individuelle accompagnement
individuel voilà qu'il apportera comment
elle se finance comment on peut être
plus en proximité auprès des parents
alors et des familles sur des
territoires on a des exemples et que des
parents de soutient la parentalité les
actions collectives titre point entre
parents enfin voilà tout ça ce sont des
objets qui sont aujourd'hui apporter que
l'on a intérêt à promouvoir encore plus
et à déployer
déployer puis enfin une des propositions
et la mise en place d'un observatoire de
la parentalité
je continue donc effectivement en termes
de constat mais qu'il a sont plutôt
effectivement sur le développement des
projets services à localité sur votre
territoire on en a parlé des fois je
vais monter structurelles les modèles
économiques fragiles et l'insuffisance
d'interlocuteur de proximité et donc à
certains moments donné l'absence de
porteur de projet sur les territoires
qui sont les moins les moins denses et
éloignés cela c'est un impact énormément
dans le sens social professionnel des
familles accompagnés en termes de
proposition de
oui et c'est bien ce qui me rassemble
aujourd'hui en termes de d'ambition
c'est de pouvoir adapter les cadres
institutionnels aux réalités locales
donc les modalités de financement des
services on est aussi sur l'ambition de
pouvoir renforcer l'offre de formation
des professionnels on a parlé tout à
l'heure mais dans le champ d'Access
social et les effectifs en lien avec les
projets en fait on est vraiment dans une
prospective c'est à dire que si demain
on se dit voilà on a besoin de 30
services aux familles quels sont les
professionnels qui sont attendus
derrière qu'est-ce que cela produit
aussi économiquement sur territoire
parce que ce
qu'il faut aussi un effet de neige et
que donc toutes les problématiques que
l'on a abordées en point A qui relève de
l'insertion de la précarité de la
fragilité tout ça en fait en tout cas la
mise en place des services formation la
professionnalisation sociale participe à
lever le territoire de manière positive
et à lever les freins
enfin les déducatifs à domicile
aujourd'hui qui est effectivement de la
compétence de la collectivité
territoriale de la Guyane ce que l'on
observe en tout cas voilà s'il y a des
délais qui sont installés
et là-dessus voilà c'est se dire comment
on peut renforcer accompagner cette
prise en charge on est sur le
renforcement donc des actions de
sensibilisation de prévention sur la vie
affective et sociale auprès des enfants
milieu scolaire et des familles mettre
en place une éducation à la parenthèse
du théâtre au sens et on a des
dispositifs qui sont à déployés qui sont
renforcés tels que les dispositifs
vacances au Camille la dernière missiles
pour le récupérer sur les initiatives
des expérimentations qui ont été portées
par la par la caisse d'annulation de
Guyane mais qui aujourd'hui encore une
fois
comment dire
le frein majeur c'est se dire mais qui
va être en capacité de porter certains
générique de déployer de pérenniser de
définir de modèle économie en cas de
pensée des
modèles suffisants pour qu'elle puisse
être viable donc à terme une question
des compétences
merci pour compléter sur la question des
politiques familiales donc au niveau de
la collectivité territoriale c'est vrai
qu'on a des schémas qui sont élaborés
néanmoins il y en a plein j'en ai
recensé pour le champ des familles 4 il
y a des schémas mais aussi des contrats
avec des partenaires institutionnels je
pense par exemple au contrat de
protection de l'enfance entre la
collectivité territoriale la
préfecture et l'ARS
ce schéma sont présents mais ils se
superposent
bien souvent
alors peut-être qu'il y aurait nécessité
les fusionner et où les simplifier pour
une meilleure nature non seulement des
partenaires mais aussi en interne au
niveau de la collectivité
même si ça relève le fonctionnement
interne mais c'est aussi
du
aux différentes
alimentation qu'on doit appliquer en
tout cas qu'on doit mettre en oeuvre
donc ce schéma sont et ses contrats sont
élaborés bien sûr en concertation avec
les différents partenaires
institutionnels mais également avec les
acteurs de terrain même si il y a encore
des améliorations à apporter mais du
fait de ce de ce manque de
transversalité et souvent il y a un
cloisonnement en interne et en externe
ça permet pas un déploiement efficient
au bénéfice des familles
le constat que j'ai également fait c'est
qu'ils m'ont parfois des instances de
concertation je vais citer un exemple
les comités locaux du travail social et
du Développement social qui ont été
instaurés en 2019 de mémoire par le Haut
Conseil du travail social n'existe pas
en Guyane et pourrait il s'agit pas de
de créer
je pense à tout va mais vraiment de voir
ce qu'il y a le plus pertinent pour une
harmonisation non seulement des
orientations mais des confinement et
pourquoi pas c'est ces instances de
concertation permettrait un réajustement
des dispositifs en cours de route et pas
d'arriver en fin de fin de contrat c'est
un dispositif ou fin de schéma pour se
rendre compte au final qu'on aurait pu
aller dans quelle direction ou réajuster
à tel ou tel moment ça permettrait de la
réactivité il a été question
effectivement des
les politiques c'est Madame Talbot qui
l'a abordé la régularisation
administrative
des personnes des usagers des différents
services effectivement ça pose souci
parce que ça engendre ça accentue en
tout cas la précarité sociale des
familles et un autre niveau il y a une
incompréhension parfois des orientations
prises par le service de l'état des
personnes qui sont nées sur le
territoire ou tout à fait régularisables
ne le sont pas et souvent on ne sait pas
pourquoi donc peut-être que là aussi il
faudrait une instance de concertation ou
en tout cas des espaces dédiés pour
pouvoir comprendre pourquoi certaines
personnes sont
privées de leurs droits en tout cas ça a
des conséquences
assez importantes non seulement pour la
personne mais pour les institutions que
sont que peuvent être pas forcément la
CAF puisque elles n'ont pas
elles sont privées de droit commun en
fait de la serre au droit commun ce qui
fait qu'au niveau de la collectivité ça
vient engorger les services et la
dispositif
et les travailleurs sociaux les services
parfois ne peuvent pas je pense
au service social de proximité c'est un
sujet territorial qui sont empêchés de
remplir leur mission notamment la
mission de prévention ce qui fait qu'on
est souvent dans du curatif que du
préventif et donc le travail associatif
au niveau de la CTG font essentiellement
de l'humanité
en terme de parentalité les besoins pour
aller très vite et sur cette main il y a
besoin d'action et de dispositifs donc
au niveau de la prévention
besoin professionnel formé diplômés
madame
le disait il y a
pardon oui par rapport au viviers qui
est présent effectivement on a le vivier
mais il faut le mettre en adéquation
mais avec la formation donc on en
revient effectivement
à la scolarisation
j'ai perdu le fil donc je vais reprendre
mon petit support que j'ai essayé de mon
dégager donc en besoin professionnel
formé diplômé besoin de dispositif et
structures de prise en charge on a
évoqué effectivement les centres
parentaux il n'y en a pas sur le
territoire
sachant les besoins peut-être également
là c'est une proposition qu'il faut de
la mesure dérogatoire pour créer des
dispositifs des structures on pense au
centre parentaux mais on pense aussi aux
établissements scolaires parce que au vu
de la population qu'on a
[Musique]
la population qui est soit en décrochage
scolaire ou pas scolarisé donc action
aussi au niveau de l'électricisme de
choses en tout cas
on est David qu'il faudrait on peut
enlever la fapette pas forcément CTG là
qu'il faudrait des mesures dérogatoires
pour réduire les temps de délai par
exemple pour le la passation des marchés
donc on a
pas explosion puisqu'on a dans le
support qui vous a été envoyé il y avait
des propositions des préconisations en
termes d'action je pensais à la création
d'un dispositif pour susciter et
accompagner l'invocation donc
sensibiliser sur les métiers en tension
là on pense particulièrement aux métiers
du social du médico-social et bien sûr
du sanitaire mais par en allant vert pas
forcément on le sait il y a des
qui sont donc la vie qui sont éloignés
sur notre territoire donc il faut aller
vers ces jeunes vers cette population et
pas attendre qu'ils arrivent à
l'université ou qu'ils soient
interminables dans le collège de la 5e
la sixième la cinquième pourquoi pas
donc on crée un dispositif donc société
accompagner les vocation accompagner
jusqu'à l'obtention si besoin du diplôme
d'état et quand je dis accompagner c'est
réfléchir à l'hébergement le transport
les moyens de subsistance donc bourse
aller vers la réussite éducative donc
pensez à un tutorat en tout cas
favoriser la réussite éducative de ce
vivier qu'on a et qu'on ne peut pas
laisser en état
voilà je vous remercie
à vous madame Chambaud
juste un petit une petite focale par
Monsieur Nogueira
une petite focale j'en suis désolé pour
lui
ah oui oui
sénateurs juste quelques chiffres pour
que vous puissiez savoir le bon temps
global des différentes prestations
sociales qui sont bien assez aujourd'hui
aux familles par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales de la Guyane aujourd'hui
c'est plus de 565 millions d'euros
toutes prestations confondues qui sont
versées sur le territoire dans le
territoire du nd bénéficie
bon notamment plus de 232 millions
d'euros à destination des bénéficiaires
de minima sociaux à noter également que
56% des allocataires dépendent
des prestations
des minima sociaux et 44% d'un locataire
dépend totalement des prestations c'est
à dire que là aujourd'hui la câble de la
Guyane c'est
565 millions d'euros et c'est surtout
des allocataires qui bénéficient
principalement et souvent uniquement
des soins des prestations sociales soit
des prestations familiales
très bien merci Monsieur Noguera donc 5
millions c'est un million 500.000 euros
injecté par jour dans l'économie
justement pour pour terminer pour
résumer juste sur l'ambition donc de
développer d'adapter de structurer
l'offre parentalité donc sur le
territoire si on veut retenir trois axes
ce serait justement la mise en place
d'une coordination
territoriale sur la parentalité d'avoir
une animation une animation du rêve de
réseau parentalité donc sur sur la
Guyane et effectivement madame Chambaud
la
presse justement souligné former et
accompagner les professionnels les
sensibiliser tous ces jeunes et les
accompagner justement sur des clients
suisses permettant par la suite d'être
complètement acteur du pays et de porter
eux-mêmes les ambitions du territoire
voilà monsieur le Président
merci nous avons
permis merci en tout cas de la qualité
si je peux vous demander de couper votre
micro quand je parle ce sera plus simple
voilà merci ouais
ça y est c'est plus c'est plus simple
pour tout le monde et il y a moins
d'écho je pense que c'est plus agréable
donc merci en tout cas de la qualité des
réponses et surtout de la qualité du
document que nous avons envoyé qui est
extrêmement complet voilà je voulais
vous le dire parce que même si on n'a
pas pu entendre et je m'en excuse auprès
de Monsieur Noguera qui est arrivé à la
fin de tout on a l'ensemble des éléments
qui nous permettent de passer au travers
des questions qui vous ont été adressées
et avant de passer la parole à mes
collègues et je pense notamment à
Victoire Marie-Laure et puis notre
collègue qui est également présent dans
la salle qui le souhaiteront j'ai une
réflexion puisque vous parliez madame de
coordonnées les acteurs sur le
territoire je moi j'ai en tête celui de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon que je connais
évidemment puisque j'en suis issu où la
caisse d'allocations familiales en
l'occurrence la Caisse de Prévoyance
sociale locale a initié un schéma
enfance famille c'est elle qui a été le
pilote avec l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire avec une vision partagée par
l'ensemble des acteurs donc je ne sais
pas si c'est le type d'organisation ou
de pilotage qui pourrait être inspiré
sur votre territoire peut-être plus
compliqué par les distances mais en tout
cas au niveau des acteurs je pense
qu'effectivement il y a certainement des
éléments de réponse à avoir parce que
j'ai bien senti qu'il y avait une
question de coordination territoriale
pour éviter notamment l'empilement des
différents schémas que vous avez évoqué
et faire en sorte qu'il soit surtout
imbriqué les uns les autres quand ils
touchent les mêmes les mêmes dimensions
et c'est ce qui nous avait motivé à
l'époque à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon on
n'avait pas fait un schéma parentalité
streetosensus on avait fait un schéma
d'action sociale et familiale au sens
large avec les acteurs que sont les
mairies la collectivité la Caisse
d'Allocation Familiales ce qui nous
permettait de couvrir l'ensemble du
champ avec des chefs de projet en
fonction des champs de compétences
finalement ce qui nous permettait
d'avoir une vision partagée donc je vous
le livre parce que c'est une réflexion
qui m'est venue à l'esprit on vous
écoutant et j'ai bien noté que ça
faisait partie des trois je dirais les
trois sources de d'évolution fortement
souhaitée à la fin de votre document
donc je voulais vous le livrer je vais
peut-être le temps laisser la parole à
nos collègues avant de pouvoir passer à
l'audition de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
donc je regarde mes collègues pour
savoir s'il a des questions peut-être
Marie-Laure victoire jasmin
victoire jasmin peut-être d'abord et
ensuite Marie-Laure finira triste de
Guyane
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la Présidente je vous remercie et
je remercie tous les intervenants que je
viens d'écouter avec beaucoup d'intérêts
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président c'est très complet mais je
crois que l'aménagement du territoire en
Guyane ça mérite vraiment qu'on puisse
s'y attarder également parce que j'ai
entendu cette recommandation qui ont été
faites par les autres et je crois que
pour les personnes qui habitent sur le
fleuve qui offre de grandes difficultés
et les enfants qui traitent la famille
pour aller à l'école en pigogue qui
reviennent en pirogue qui ont des
grandes difficultés donc tout a été
décrit j'avais pas revenu là-dessus
parce que là comme vous l'avez dit des
éléments vous ont été transmis mais je
crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on prenne
en compte les situations dramatiques
vivent les Guyanais et à certains
endroits en Guyane effectivement un tour
de suicide trop important chez les
jeunes et il faut une attention toute
particulière en tant que rapporteur je
souhaiterais vraiment qu'on puisse
mettre l'accent sur toutes les
difficultés qui ont été décrites et sur
la nécessité de former là ça a été dit
j'ai beaucoup apprécié les interventions
qui parlent de la formation parce qu'il
est question de cela mais ne pas
forcément mettre toutes les formations
même endroit il faut vraiment et trouver
les voies les moyens pour former déjà à
distance mais le rapport de la Défenseur
des droits nous on va démontré il y a
quelques jours qu'il y a de grandes
difficultés sur cette zone de territoire
y compris la bien évidemment pour
l'électrolyse pour également
l'illettrisme mais aussi l'accès aux
réseaux ça a été dit mais nous devons
peut-être changer le modèle économique
mais aussi le modèle de prise en compte
des formations parce que faire des
formations différenciées sur certains
territoires et mettre en place des
possibilités de va leur vie pour te
trouver des des outils différents pour
l'ensemble du territoire parce que c'est
très compliqué de circuler en Guyane
d'aller d'un point de vue parce que
c'est très éloigné et c'est des secours
mais aussi les difficultés réelles donc
je n'ai pas de questions précises étant
donné que comme vous monsieur le
Président qu'il y a des données qui ont
été créées ils nous ont été transmis je
remercie je vous remercie d'autant plus
madame la Présidente et aussi vous
monsieur le Président Artano pour
l'intérêt que vous avez porté sur la
situation de nos différents territoires
et de façon singulière sur la Guyane
merci beaucoup
merci le rapporteur je vais mettre ton
laisser la parole à mes autres collègues
peut-être commencer par Marie-Laure
finiraors qui avait levé la main
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs j'ai
beaucoup apprécié effectivement les
interventions comme viennent de le dire
la collègue victoire jasmin j'ai deux
questions qui demandent pas de réponse
longue alors une première question à
Madame Talbot sur le rapport sur les
inégalités de santé en Guyane qui date
du 4 mars 2021 avec comme grande
ambition de permettre à chaque femme
enceinte ou qu'elle réside en Guyane de
bénéficier d'une visite prénatale au
cours du premier trimestre de grossesse
nous savons que la surveillance de la
grossesse démarre souvent très en retard
en Guyane et empêche ainsi le dépistage
d'éventuels complications médicales
pouvez-vous me dire quel pourcentage de
femmes enceintes bénéficient aujourd'hui
de cette visite prénatale j'ai une
question aussi pour Madame Aïssa
touchambault j'ai eu l'occasion
d'alerter madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État en charge de l'enfance
sur la situation de l'accueil des jeunes
dans les familles hébergeantes
certainement des mesures seront
annoncées dans les semaines qui viennent
parfois il serait intéressant d'avoir la
vie de Madame Chambaud qui est toujours
sur le terrain tous les jours voilà
président merci beaucoup pour les
réponses je laisse le soin à nos amis de
Guyane de te répondre cher
pour répondre à la question alors je
peux pas répondre vraiment à la question
largement tout ce que je sais
qu'aujourd'hui le réseau pérennité a mis
en place un dispositif pour couvrir
les soins des femmes qui n'ont pas de
couverture santé ça veut dire des femmes
qui viennent des pays voisins ensemble
et qui ne peuvent pas bénéficier de la
couverture santé donc il y a dispositif
de
consultation gratuite au niveau des
échographies donc c'est prise en charge
par le réseau de périnatalité mais à
part ce dispositif qui est financé qui
est payé par le réseau je peux pas vous
donner plus d'éléments mais quand vous
allez revenir idéal j'espère bien qu'on
pourra se rencontrer rencontrer Madame
Bernard qui vous donnera plus
d'informations
merci je prends le relais donc pour
compléter la réponse de Madame Talbot
première question madame la sénatrice
cette question des visites prénatales
faisaient partie de c'était un point du
contrat Protection de l'Enfance entre la
CTG ARS et les services de l'État
donc là aussi on est confronté à la
pénurie de professionnels donc là
c'était j'ai pour être honnête a été en
incapacité de remplir cette mission
faute de pouvoir recruter parce que le
financement qui avait été
qui avait été allouée ne pouvait
permettre que
n'était pas dédié à financer des postes
existants c'était vraiment des nouveaux
postes du recrutement donc voilà pas de
chocolat
voilà et donc pour répondre à votre
deuxième question sur la les familles
hébergeantes on parle bien de femmes
hébergenteuiles pas des assistants
familiaux donc le sujet est toujours
d'actualité
alors j'ai interpellé le cabinet du
président
serrez récemment là-dessus je sais que
c'est la collègue amirobos en chow-chow
qui a repris ce
dispositif qui qui va y travailler j'ai
pas forcément plus de d'éléments là
dessus au niveau de la collectivité mais
je sais que le grand conseil coutumier
ça saisit de la de la question
il travaille dessus depuis plusieurs
mois déjà j'ai eu l'opportunité
justement d'avoir des réunions avec les
organisations autochtones et le bon
conseil coutumier alors là ce que il
faut en tout cas un dispositif
stable fiable une organisation fiable et
de financement pérenne il faut vraiment
il faut pas prendre le cette
problématique uniquement sous l'angle
des familles hébergeantes mais il faut
pouvoir proposer aux familles un
dispositif complet donc avec les
professionnels et avec autour
la différence acteurs donc il faut là
aussi de la conservation donc on ne
parle pas de zéro il y avait des
proposition qui avait été faites par le
la direction de l'éducation au niveau de
la collectivité le Grand Conseil que tu
mets et le GCS a fait également je vais
pas vous déprimer le cycle je n'ai pas
en tête mais il y a des préconisations
qui ont été faites moi-même j'avais fait
au président servile une proposition
d'organisation donc là il faut les
financements et les professionnels pour
mettre en place un vrai dispositif
si vous le permettez madame la sénatrice
je voudrais quand même apporter la
vision de la CAF c'est du sein
effectivement de
l'hébergement de ces jeunes puisque la
CAF est quand même indirectement
touché puisque ce qu'il nous faut ce
sont des associations qui soient en
capacité
d'accompagner les jeunes donc ils sont
hébergés dès lors qu'ils ne sont qui ne
sont pas en cas dans le domicile l'idée
c'est qu'il ne soit pas livré à
eux-mêmes qui ne soit pas oisif dès lors
qu'ils sont sortis de l'école qui
faisaient des activités du sport
activité culturelles qui se rencontrent
entre eux entre communautés mais aussi
qu'on puisse accompagner la mixité
sociale entre les enfants et entre ces
jeunes et ce qui faut encore Emmanuel ma
collaboratrice l'assouligné c'est de la
générique c'est les associations de
l'ingénierie on
est des projets qui soient
mûri réfléchi en ce sens de sorte qu'il
y ait en fait une prise en charge
globale du jeûne qui est logé en famille
en famille d'accueil
pour ma part je pense qu'on a le droit
de seconde l'important de les
associations en les a encore faut-il de
nous et là on a annonce la
responsabilité que la productivité soit
capable de dire ce qu'elle veut qu'on
propose quelque chose et après voilà et
donc pour finir il y a quand même il
faut garder le collège jeune les élèves
gardent le lien avec leurs parents et là
se posent à nouveau la question du
transport fluvial et à l'aérienne c'est
vraiment là une catastrophe
j'ai écouté je vous remercie de ces
réponses et
puisque je ne vois pas demain lever chez
mes collègues je vous propose de mettre
un terme à cette à cette table ronde en
vous remerciant vraiment sincèrement de
la qualité des réponses et de la vision
que vous avez apporté ce qui vous permet
quand même à défaut de pouvoir nous
déplacer d'avoir une vision plus
exhaustive avec les éclairages
évidemment de vos de nos collègues de
Guyane en tant que de besoin donc merci
beaucoup mesdames et messieurs pour pour
votre disponibilité et nous allons
maintenant enclenché la table ronde sur
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon à très bientôt
merci à vous
merci à tous autour de la table au
plaisir
merci
beaucoup merci au revoir